perform the indicated operations then
simplify so we have three rational
expressions here and we're going to
subtract this one we're going to add
this one so just like we if we were
adding and subtracting a bunch of
fractions we really have to find a
common denominator here and to figure
out a common denominator we have to
figure out the least common multiple of
X plus 5 of 2x minus 10 and x squared
minus 25 and to find the least common
multiple we really want to factor these
out and make sure that that least common
multiple that that common denominator
has all of the constituent factors in it
so this can't be factored anymore X plus
5 that's about as simple as you can get
it 2x minus 10 we can factor out a 2 and
it becomes 2 times X minus 5 so we
factor that out and then x squared minus
25 you might recognize as a difference
of squares so that's the same thing as X
plus 5 times X minus 5 just factored
that out and so if we want to have a
least common multiple so let me rewrite
each of these with that common
denominator here that the least common
multiple the least common multiple is
going to be it's going to have to be
something that has X plus 5 in it it's
going to have to have a 2 in it it's
going to have an X minus 5 in it and as
well and we've already decided it has to
have an X plus 5 and X minus 5 in it so
it's got to have a 2 it's got to have a
2 it's got to have an X plus 5 it's got
to have an X plus 5 it's got to have an
X minus 5 in it it's got to have an X
minus 5 in it
and it's got to have an X plus 5 times
an X minus 5 well we've already got that
there so no need to write it again so
that right there is our is our common
denominator so let's write it out so
let's rewrite each of these expressions
with that common denominator so 2 times
X plus 5 times X minus 5 and then right
over here I'll write again 2 times X
plus 5 times X minus 5 once you get used
to this you might be able to just write
out the common denominator once and then
figure out the appropriate things to
multiply the numerators by but I want to
make sure we go through every step for
these videos just so we make sure we
understand what's going on so to go from
x plus 5 to 2 times X plus 5 times X
minus 5 what do we have to multiply X
plus 5
bye well we have to multiply it in order
to get this we're multiplying it by a2
we're multiplying the X plus 5 by 2 and
we're also multiplying it by an X minus
5 so if we're multiplying the
denominator by a 2 and an X minus 5 we
have to multiply the numerator by a 2
and an X must at an X minus 5 so if we
multiply 2 times X minus 5 times 1
we'll get 2 times X minus 5 and we don't
even have to write this one now we're
subtracting over here and to get from 2
x2 times X minus 5 to this over here
what did we have to multiply it by well
we have the 2 times X minus 5 right over
there we have to multiply it by an X
plus 5 this is the part that is new we
have to multiply it by an X plus 5 we
have to multiply this denominator right
here by X plus 5 to get this denominator
so if you multiply the denominator by X
plus 5 you want to multiply the
numerator by X plus 5 as well so the
numerator is going to be 2 times X plus
5 just took the 2 multiply it by X plus
5 exactly what we did to the denominator
we multiplied it by X plus 5 then we
have this last this last expression
right over here
we went from we went from let me do this
in a new color
we went from X plus 5 times X minus 5 to
X plus 5 times X minus 5 times 2 so to
go from this denominator to this
denominator we just have to multiply by
2 if you multiply the denominator by 2
you should multiply the numerator by 2
so multiply 2 times 2x you're going to
get you're going to get 4x so all I did
here is I multiplied it by 2 let me make
it clear to get from this to this I
multiplied it by I multiplied it by X
plus 5x plus 5 and then to go from and
then to go from there to there I
multiplied it by 2 times X minus 5 and
over here I should use instead of
writing x to I that I should multiply by
2 don't want to get the multiplication
symbol confused with the X variable and
of course there was a positive out here
so we are now ready to do our adding and
subtracting and we could view this just
for simplicity just make it clear
subtracting this thing is the same thing
as adding the negative of it and that
makes it a little bit simpler so let's
put our common denominator down let's
put our common denominator down so all
of this business is going to be in our
denominators can be 2 times X plus 5
times X minus 5 and our numerator is now
going to be and I'm going to multiply
this out so that we can properly add
terms so 2 times X minus 5 is 2 X minus
10 and then we have a negative 2 times X
plus 5 so that's going to be negative 2x
and the negative 2 times 5 is negative
10 and then we're going to have a plus
4x plus 4x over here plus 4x and then we
can simplify this thing and so that you
have a 2x you're subtracting a 2x those
guys cancel out you have you have then
you're left with just a 4x so you're
left with just a 4x and then minus 10
minus 10 so 4x minus 20 over over 2
times X plus 5 times X minus 5 and then
let's see we can factor out a 4 up here
so if we factor out a 4 this becomes 4
times X minus 5 and then if we assume if
we assume that we're that we're not
dealing with X is equal to positive 5
because that would make the denominator
undefined we can we can divide the
numerator and the denominator by X minus
5 and so if we divide the numerator in
the denominator by X minus 5 those
cancel out and we could divide the
numerator in the denominator by 2 since
they're both divisible by 2 that 4
divided by 2 is 2 2 divided by 2 is 1 so
in the numerator we're just left with a
2 and in the denominator we're just left
with an X plus 5 we're just left with an
X plus 5 now I want to be very careful
here because this expression up here if
we really want this final answer that we
got to be truly identical to this
expression over here just a simplified
version we have to make sure that it has
the
same domain if say this was part of the
function definition you want to make
sure that it's valid for the same X's
and not anymore if you wanted them to be
truly identical and this up here is not
valid so the domain the domain if you
view this is one entire expression or
one entire function definition the
domain the domain would be all all real
X's except except X is equal to X cannot
be equal to negative 5 or X cannot be
equal to positive 5 because that would
create make this denominator equal to 0
or X is equal to 5 and so if you want
these two things to be identical they
have to have the same domain if you want
them to be most algebra classes people
will not be particularly and you know
maybe you don't want them to be the same
function maybe you want to lose maybe
you want it to be defined when X is
equal to positive 5 but if you want them
to be truly the same expression you have
to have the same domain so you could you
know your domain you could you would
want to say it is all real X's except if
you were to just do the domain for this
thing if you just saw this expression
right here say okay X can't be equal to
negative 5 but if you wanted to be at
the same domain
so let me write except X is equal to
negative 5 and X equal to and so this
right here is just the domain for this
thing but if we want to have the same
domain as the original expression we
would also throw in and X and X is equal
to 5